so I go over there and I'm talking
congratulations all these Academy Awards
and all this sort of stuff and I say now
now what Jim I mean just one best
picture Best Director best best this
best that he opened his desk drawer and
he pulls out two scripts one is called
Elita battle Angel and the other one is
called Avatar and I was I didn't know
what a lead a battle Angel meant I
didn't know what Avatar meant I didn't
even know they were full scripts too
they weren't treatments they were
scripts and I looked and I said uh a gym
uh well cool which one are you gonna do
and he said I don't know Michael I have
to wait for the technology to catch up